in our own times I'm quiet this is
Freeman and he's been up a tree for
three days and two nights I was drunk
the flood and how long have been he
tonight and how long haven't had a good
sleep but at how long we first met him
last Tuesday he's been living in this
forest camp since last August with his
dog cheeky on the edge of some steel
fencing behind which diggers are carving
out the route for the high speed rail
track hs2 he wants to stop them that
bailiffs warned he had to move and so
are you gonna move out and if they make
me so after what carry you out or they'd
have to catch me and in carrying me out
last week just beyond Freeman's forest
camp in coal Valley Oxbridge a group of
protesters were evicted from a field
from Sky News this the first protest
site against the rail line set up in
October 2017 some of the people forced
out of here had been there for much of
that time hs2 it's a horrendous project
it will destroy our nature reserves it
destroys my job everything is passage
about in the Nature Reserve a week later
we come back to the protest camp so this
land was completely cleared out last
week HS to say they had the right to do
it because they owned the land and they
got a court order to evict the people on
it in
last year but what's happened is that
the protesters have simply retreated
back to the woods where Freeman is
camped out well I've just been told not
to let you in sir
yeah the general of dispute in the fact
that you can come in over we have a
right to walk down there and you don't
have a right to stop us and you can't
stop us well we can sir we are the
bailiffs block our entry down the
footpath but we find an alternative
route into the camp and here discovered
some of the protesters have been fenced
into a new area while Freeman and one
other campaigner have taken to the trees
and how long do you intend to stay out
there the standoff came the day after
the woodland trust warned that hs2 would
damage nearly 700 local wildlife sites
and more than a hundred ancient
woodlands hs2 though has proposed
creating a green corridor along the
route and says there will be no loss of
biodiversity here the bailiffs strategy
was to block Freeman in so he couldn't
come down for supplies in the night then
the following morning they chased him
further up the tree eventually he does
come down and gets medical attention and
what's happening now okay visions come
blurred and feet and extremities and
London hs2 says the land here is legally
possessed and protests are costly to the
taxpayer and a threat to the safety of
the public and their workers but with
more camps like this up the line this is
set to be a recurring problem
Jason Farrell's going use